[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM COIMBRA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Adam Coimbra, and
I'm a Product Manager
on the Google Assistant.
SACHIT MISHRA:
I'm Sachit Mishra.
I'm on the Google Assistant
Developer Relations team.
JAMIE HIRSCHHORN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jamie Hirshhorn from our
Product Partnerships team.
I work on early
stage integrations
with lots of our developers.
ADAM COIMBRA: Cool.
So welcome to the Introduction
to Building Actions
for the Google Assistant.
This is our overview session.
So if you're totally
new to all this,
hopefully it'll
pique your interest
in the other great
deep dive sessions
we have at I/O this year.
So I'll be going through
the why you should build--
so the motivation and background
for building for the Assistant.
And then we'll hear my
favorite part from Sachit--
how to build; the deep
dive into the tech.
And finally, Jamie
will explain how
to really flourish
with the platform
and optimize your actions
to get more value.
So it seems like we see a
major shift in technology
every decade or so.
Mainframes-- or so I'm told--
the desktops, the web, mobile.
For example, with the
move from web to mobile,
we saw an explosion
of new devices,
new ways to consume content,
interact with services
via apps in the mobile web.
So with each shift, computing
becomes more ubiquitous,
and people expect technology to
do more and more to help them
with their day-to-day lives.
But all these devices
and services also
increase complexity, and
they can get in the way,
creating confusion when we're
just trying to get things done.
So that's why we're so
excited about the Assistant,
because we hope that it can
solve some of these problems
by orchestrating across this
ocean of services and devices
at our disposal and allow
us to just naturally express
what we want-- literally
say it out loud,
and get back what we ask for
in an equally natural way.
So the Google Assistant
is our approach
to this new era of
digital assistants
and conversational computing.
And we're starting to see
that long-term vision come
to fruition.
Users are asking for
things in new ways.
They're saying, I want to know.
I want to do.
I want to hear.
And they're expecting to be
able to complete more and more
complex tasks with assistance.
And they're asking for
their favorite brands
to be available in this
new modality across all
their devices.
So a great example that you
probably saw this morning
is Starbucks.
Soon, you'll be able to ask
Starbucks for your usual,
and in minutes, have your
drink waiting for you
at the closest location.
So this is a service that many
of us use on a daily basis,
and we're bringing an entirely
new level of convenience
and seamlessness
to this use case.
So how do we do this?
Well, Actions on Google
is the developer platform
for the Google Assistant.
Now, if you're
already participating
in Google's existing
ecosystems-- like Search,
Android, Play, Maps--
well, we're working
to automatically bring
your services and
content to the Assistant.
But Actions on Google is the
way to target the Assistant
directly.
So let's say you already have
a web app or a mobile app.
You've optimized
every pixel of it,
and you're asking what's next.
Bring it to the Assistant.
But don't go rewrite
your whole app.
Think about the use cases
that make sense in this space.
For example, Starbucks
focused on the daily routine
of ordering your usual
coffee on the way to work.
So we want Actions on Google to
be this powerful new ecosystem
for developers to participate
in this new Assistant
space and leverage
Google's investments
in AI-first technology.
But for you to invest,
we expect you to ask us,
what do I get in return?
And there's three
things that I think
are really important for us
to provide for this to be
a valuable platform.
Those are reach, monetization,
and reengagement.
First of all, we
have to provide you
with reach, which is access
to a wide audience of users.
Now, users are already
coming to the Assistant
to perform over 1
million actions,
but the ecosystem is
far from saturated.
As users come to get more
and more things done,
there's a huge
opportunity for your brand
to get discovered and
fulfill unmet needs.
And they're performing
these actions
across a huge range of
devices and contexts,
from voice-enabled speakers
like the Google Home
to phones to Android Auto to
TVs, Chromebooks, and more,
bringing the number of devices
where you can reach users
to over 500 million.
Another component to
the audience expansion
is the global user base.
Actions are now available
in 25 plus locales,
with more coming this year.
So once you have access
to this wide audience,
you need to be able to actually
run your business, make money.
So last year, we added
transactional capabilities
for physical goods and services.
And soon we're expanding this to
digital goods and subscriptions
as well.
Now, we've built out an
end-to-end transactional
experience completely native
to the conversational modality.
Using Google Pay,
we can seamlessly
take payments from users.
And with Google Identity, we
can sign them into your app
and even register
for new accounts.
And now these experiences are
going to be even more seamless,
with fully eyes-free support
for both Payments and Identity.
So we have a great
session on Thursday,
actually, on adding
transactional capabilities
if you'd like to learn more.
Now, the final key to
making this successful
is to create a
sustainable platform.
And reengagement is all
about creating a loyal base
of users that keep coming
back to your action over
and over again.
Now, I'm a product
manager on the Assistant.
I can tell you that
our team constantly
thinks about what we
call user journeys.
And we've analyzed
tons of usage behavior
and found three
critical journeys
where we think we can
really assist users--
in the morning when they're
trying to get out the door,
during their commute so they
can be productive on the go,
and in the evening when they're
trying to de-stress and relax.
So in these key moments,
users are highly engaged,
and they keep coming
back to the Assistant.
And by optimizing
for these moments,
the Assistant can drive
organic discovery and retention
to your actions.
So if you'd like to learn
more about driving engagement,
come to Thursday's session
on building a user base
for your actions.
So we really do believe there's
an amazing opportunity here
for you to get a wide audience,
make money, and then get
more loyalty and retention.
But what should you actually
build to get in on this?
Well, we offer a
range of integrations.
And the first one is
vertical programs.
So these are direct
integrations with Google,
and they're great because with
a simple API implementation,
Google creates an entire
user experience for you.
Now, it's been amazing to
see the success and adoption
of our Smart Home API.
As you've heard,
it now integrates
with over 5,000 devices.
A single API ties together
the Google Assistant
and the device maker's
infrastructure,
which lets Google to understand
increasingly complex commands
and support a wide
range of understanding.
So we have a great talk on Smart
Home integrations on Thursday,
so please visit
to find out more.
And this is just one example of
how powerful vertical programs
are by enabling great
user experiences
with simple integrations.
Now, for publishers, we
offer content actions.
This extends our long
history of structured data
markup with Google Search.
You can optimize your structured
data for the Assistant
to enable great voice
experiences with your content.
So for example, a user might
ask the Assistant about recipes
and see a rich set of
results from Food Network.
Because the content is
optimized for the Assistant,
we can provide
voice instructions
and guide them through
the recipe step-by-step.
If you're already doing
structured data for Search,
you're on the right track.
And we have a deep
dive Wednesday
on taking the next step
to actually optimize
that for the Assistant.
Next, with app
actions, we're helping
you to discover the core
capabilities of your existing
Android app.
So you can expose actions and
content from your Android app
by linking it to
semantic intents
in the actions.XML file.
This allows Google to map user
queries for content and actions
to your app and then
feature you in suggestions
across the Android launcher,
Smart Text selection, Google
Search app, and Google Assistant
on Android and the Play Store.
So you see, app actions
will allow your app
to get further reach and
engagement with our users.
And you can find all about this,
actually, just today at 5:00
PM in the talk, Getting
Started with App Actions.
So these are great
ways to integrate
if you have an
existing Android app
or a vertical or
content-specific use case.
But many of the most
successful ecosystems,
like the web and mobile,
are powerful because they
have a generalized integration
model that allows developers
to build custom experiences for
any use case they can imagine.
For the Assistant, this model is
called conversational actions.
These are immersive
conversational experiences
completely custom
for your brand.
They're a direct conversation
between you and your user.
So here's a cool example
of conversational action.
It's called California
Surf Report,
and it helps you
find wave conditions
if you live in California.
Let's walk through
the user experience.
So a user says a query like,
talk to California Surf Report,
and this is like the voice
version of a shortcut
on the mobile home screen.
So the Google Assistant is then
able to look through its index
of actions and finds a match.
So now it's time to
let the user know
that it's going to
hand over control
to California Surf Report.
So it says something
like, sure, connecting you
with that action.
The user hears an earcon,
which is like an audio version
of an icon.
It's a distinctive sound
letting the user know
a transition is taking place.
And now the user is conversing
directly with the action.
The action welcomes the
user in its own voice,
explaining its functionality
and asking an initial question.
And finally, the action
is able to respond
with the information the
user asked for and ends
the conversation.
We hear another earcon
letting the user
know the Assistant is back in
control of the conversation.
So this is a powerful,
open-ended model
where you can build any sort
of conversational interaction
that you can imagine.
And it's not just about voice.
So Assistant is on so
many different devices,
and many of them have screens.
Now, adding rich
visuals to supplement
a conversational interface
makes it far more
engaging and delightful
for your users.
Here are some examples
of that same interaction
with California Surf
Report on visual devices.
As you can see, it creates
an immersive experience,
responding to the
user with rich visuals
as well as visual output--
as well as voice output, sorry.
Now, supporting different
modalities and form factors
has always been a
challenge for platforms
like the web and mobile.
And when you build
for the Assistant,
you're targeting an even more
diverse range of modalities,
from voice-only
like Google Home,
to voice-forward devices
like the new smart displays,
intermodal devices
like the phone,
and visual-only
like smartwatches.
But our conversational
action APIs are multimodal.
With a single implementation
of our rich response API,
Google is able to
scale your experience
across all these devices.
If you're interested in
learning more about this,
we have a great session on
Wednesday called Design Actions
for the Assistant.
Of course, no matter how
smart these APIs are,
it still takes some work and
technical know-how to get up
and running.
And that's why we provide
templates to get you started.
This is a super fun and easy
way to build for the Assistant.
No programming
knowledge required.
You can create fun and
engaging conversational actions
like personality quiz,
trivia, and flashcards.
All you have to do is come
to the Actions Console
and follow a step-by-step
wizard to get
started with the template.
Then you just fill out a
Google Sheets spreadsheet
with the content.
For example, for flashcard,
there is a row for each card,
and columns for the
two sides, and a hint.
So I'd love for
everyone here to tonight
go and spend 20, 30 minutes and
build a conversational action
with templates.
You'll see it's
really fun and easy.
Of course, I know most of you
are developers, so that's never
going to be satisfying enough.
You probably have a use
case we've never thought of,
or you want to create
something truly custom,
or you're just interested
in this conversational space
and want to start
building your skills.
So let's hear a little
bit about how to build
custom conversational actions.
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIT MISHRA: All
right, hey, everyone.
So Adam's just laid
out a bunch of options
for integrating with
the Google Assistant.
And what I want to do is I want
to walk us through building
a conversational action.
And to do that, I want to
share a journey with you of how
I got to here--
a fully-functional,
high-quality, conversational
action that I
built from scratch.
And what it does is it gives
the user some information
about any given
programming language,
specifically
information that will
inform whether to use that
language in an upcoming
project.
So like many of my
colleagues at Google--
and I'm sure many of you here--
I have had the profound gift
of sharing my programming
knowledge with others.
Back when I was in high
school in South Florida,
I volunteered at a youth
program in my community
where we taught the
basics of programming
to middle school and
high school students.
And this was in a community
where a lot of these students
wouldn't have had
exposure to this knowledge
without these kinds of classes.
And after high school, when
I moved away for college,
I had to say goodbye
to these students
with whom I had
worked for so long.
And I've also been
looking for another way
to reach out to them.
But lucky for me, a lot
of them have grown up
and they now have Android
phones and other devices
with the Google
Assistant built in.
So I thought that the Assistant
would be a great platform
to reach out to them once
again, with an old lesson
about choosing the right
language for the right project.
So from all of the options
that Adam had laid out,
I had to figure out which
one was the best for me.
So I needed to build something
that was educational,
but I have my own brand,
my own way of teaching.
And I want to own
that back and forth.
I want to control the dialogue.
So I needed conversation.
So I went to the Actions
on Google documentation
and I learned more about
building conversations.
And I learned that
it basically works
by sending your
endpoint a request
for every turn of dialogue.
And it gives you complete
control over the conversation.
You've got your own voice,
separate from the Google
Assistant, and the conversation
ends when you decide--
or when the user cancels out.
But that's pretty
daunting, especially
for someone who has
historically built
graphical applications, right?
So I wanted to learn more.
So when it comes to
any new platform,
there are four
things I care about--
design, tools,
infrastructure, and testing.
So with this whole new paradigm
of interacting with the user,
I wanted to start with design.
So I learned that one
big thing to consider
is your Actions persona.
Human beings-- we have
this remarkable habit
of comparing any
human-like interaction
to a real human presence.
And I promise that this is
going to happen to your Action.
So find a persona for your
Action, and always ask,
what would this persona
say or do in this moment?
And how did I come
up with my persona?
Well, first I came up
with some adjectives
that describe my brand, right?
So I'm a little bit
geeky and I'm over-eager
and I'm talkative when
the topic is something
that I really care about.
And then I came up with
some characters that
embody this in the real life.
So I could use an engineer, like
myself, or maybe a librarian.
Or if you're, like any of
my friends, a video game
enthusiast, they tend
to be this way as well.
And then I chose one,
and I wittled it down
to a description.
So I came up with a
digital librarian program
that's been migrated
from legacy architecture
to architecture since
the '70s, and so it
knows a lot about
programming languages.
All right, so then I had
another choice to make.
I had to choose a voice, right?
And I realized I had a
couple options here, OK?
So the platform comes with some
built-in synthesized voices,
both female and male.
And that makes it really easy to
just plug in your text and go.
And you can even get
some advanced control
over the delivery of that
output, which Speech Synthesis
Markup Language.
And that allows you
to control some things
like the pitch and the speed
and insert little breaks,
and even embed audio
clips in the output.
The other option is I could go
with a recorded voice talent,
and I could use that instead.
And this has the potential
to take my experience
to the next level,
but I would actually
have to go find some
voice talent help,
and I would have to localize
my recordings if I wanted to be
supported in more regions.
So I just didn't have
the resources for that.
That wasn't going
to work for me.
All right, so now I figured
out a couple design principles
to guide me, and I can
jump into the tools.
The first place I went
is the Actions Console.
And here I created a project.
And I can see all these
options for getting started.
I can see the different
categories of actions
that I can build.
I can simulate my action
when it's in development.
I can check out analytics on
the action when it's published.
I can edit the directory
listing that users
are going to see in the
Assistant Directory.
And the beautiful thing
about this project
is that it's actually
backed by the Google Cloud
and by Firebase.
So all of my related technical
assets can live in one place.
All right, cool.
So I can create a project, and
I can create an endpoint in,
let's say, Firebase
using the same project.
But this endpoint
is going to receive
the text of the
user's utterance,
and I need to process that, OK?
But I don't have a PhD in
natural language processing,
and my machine learning
is shaky at best.
All right, so what do I do,
use regular expressions?
So the next thing
I figured out is
that Google is going to
give me this amazing tool
for natural language
understanding called
Dialogflow.
And it does exactly what I need.
It turns that unstructured,
natural language input
into a structured representation
that my endpoint can consume.
Dialogflow sits in the
middle between the Assistant
and my server, and
it does that for me
with hybrid machine learning
powered intent matching
and entity recognition.
All right, so we'll dive
into those in a second.
But first, I just wanted to
build one turn of dialogue.
So I dug more deeply,
and I figured out
how to at least build this.
And so the way this
is going to work
is that the user's going to
invoke my action by name using
one of our supported
phrases like talk to,
and then the magical Google
Assistant infrastructure
is going to handle that like it
would any other user utterance,
but it's going to realize
that my action is the best
to handle it.
So my Dialogflow agent is
going to receive a request,
and it's going to realize
it's being invoked.
So it's going to
trigger something called
a welcome intent,
and this is a default
that every Dialogflow
agent comes with.
All right, so how do I do this?
From the Actions Console in
the Project Overview page,
I can create a custom
action through Dialogflow.
And in Dialogflow, I'm going
to modify the welcome intent.
And I'm going to remove
the default greetings
that it gives me.
All right, so now
I need to come up
with some sort of
greeting for the user.
And I'm thinking about it,
and I can't really come up
with anything captivating.
And then I remembered,
what would my persona
say in this moment?
And so with that, I came
up with a couple geeky
and over-eager variations
of welcome prompts
which asked the
user for a language.
Something like, hi, there.
I can tell you all about
programming languages.
Which one do you
want to hear about?
So I'm greeting the user.
I'm orienting them to
what my Action can do,
and then I'm prompting them.
And so from there, I can head
over to the Actions Console
through the Dialogflow
Integrations page,
and I can start
messing with my Action.
And if I wanted
to in the future,
I could do some really
cool stuff here.
So I could taper the
greeting for repeat users,
or I could change it
based on how long it's
been since that specific user
has last spoken to my action.
And by the way,
there's a session
at 10:30 AM on day three
about personalizing
actions for users.
So if you're interested,
check that one out.
But anyway, I've got a
dialogue started now.
All right, so that
was easy enough, OK?
But now the user is
going to respond,
and there's a million
ways that they
could answer that
question of which language
they want to learn about, right?
So how do I account
for all this variation?
I'm going to use a
Dialogflow intent.
All right, so the way
Dialogflow intents work
is that you train them to listen
for phrases that the user is
going to speak in
each turn of dialogue.
And then each semantically
similar set of phrases
is called an intent, right?
So with the power
of machine learning,
when the user says anything
similar to the phrases you've
provided at any point
in the conversation,
Dialogflow is going
to match that intent.
So I created an intent
which listened for the user
saying something like,
tell me about Kotlin,
or should I use JavaScript?
And then Dialogflow knows
that they're basically
asking about a language,
and it extracts from that
which language they want.
Now, how does it do that?
Well, I had defined
a custom entity
in Dialogflow called
Languages which
lists out all of the programming
languages that I support.
And how am I going to
account for the variation
in the way each programming
language is spoken?
Programming languages
have nicknames.
Well, Dialogflow offers the
feature of designating synonyms
for each canonical value.
And Dialogflow also comes with
a bunch of built-in system
entities that it
already knows about,
things like temperature and
cities and dates and times.
All right, so now
at this point, I
need to actually
dynamically respond
to the user with some
information about the language
that they've chosen.
So I'm going to need to expand
my infrastructure a little bit.
OK, so we've got the interaction
that I've already built--
that one turn of dialogue.
But now the user's
going to respond
with a request to know about
some specific language.
Let's say they say,
tell me about Kotlin.
And this time, the
Google Assistant
is going to hand off
directly to my Action,
because the user's already
entered the dialogue.
It's going to handle the
speech-to-text transcription,
and Dialogflow is going to match
which language intent that I
described earlier.
But this time,
instead of responding,
it's going to reach out
to my WebHook hosted
on Cloud Functions
for Firebase, and it's
going to dynamically pull
information about that language
and present it to the user.
So how did I tell
Dialogflow to do that?
Well, I set the URL
of my Cloud Function
in the Fulfillment
settings of Dialogflow.
And here I can edit some
Off and Header settings
for the post request
that my WebHook receives.
And there's also an inline
editor in this page,
so you can actually edit your
Cloud Functions code right
in the Dialogflow console.
All right, let's talk
a little bit more
about building one
of these WebHooks.
So since I'm using Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
I'm going to be using Node.js.
And the first thing I'm going
to do in my index.js file
is I'm going to
create a simple JSON
mapping of language strings
to some helpful fact
about that language.
And then later,
in the same file,
I'm going to use the Actions on
Google Node.js client library
to handle the which_language
intent from Dialogflow
with a callback.
And so in that
callback, I'm actually
going to respond with some
fact from that mapping
that I had defined
earlier, and I'm
going to prompt the user to
ask about another language.
So I'm furthering
the conversation.
And at this point, I've got
something pretty substantial
to test.
So I can go back to that
simulator in the Actions
Console, and I can play
around more with it
like a natural user.
And at this point,
I might actually
use some of the debugging
information on the right side.
And I can actually
simulate the experience
as if I was a user on
different surface types.
All right, so
speaking of surfaces,
the experience right
now is a little bit
dry on a screen device.
So how can I change that?
Well, one thing
I can do is I can
add more visual descriptions
of the information.
So here I'm using a BasicCard
class from the Node.js library
to construct a rich visual
response for the Go programming
language.
And it has a couple cool things.
It has a title, and it
has some text, and even
some imagery and alternative
text for accessibility.
In this case, the
image is Go's mascot.
And I've even got a button
with a link to Go's website.
And notice how the API gives
me really granular control
over the construction
of the response--
even the placement
of the chat bubbles
above and below the BasicCard.
So let's say I needed to
guide the user a bit more--
they didn't know which language
they could choose from.
So I can create a list
of programming languages
that I support.
And in the library,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a
mapping of each language
to a row in the list with
its own title and image.
And then I'm going to
present the options
to the user as a list, and
the user can tap or say
whichever they choose.
But what if I wanted to
emphasize the graphics?
I can change one
word in the code.
List becomes carousel.
And the user can now
swipe through and browse
the options more visually.
But this is all on a
screen device, right?
What if the user's
on a smart speaker
and I want to show
them something visual?
Well, here's a
super cool feature,
and it's one that empowers
you, as developers, to leverage
the immersiveness
of the Assistant.
I can check if the user is
on a screen device currently,
and if not, whether
they have any screen
devices with the Assistant
linked to their account.
And if they do, I can actually
ask them to switch devices.
So the dialogue's going
to end on their speaker,
and they're going to get a
notification on the phone
where they can
resume the dialogue.
And I even get control over
what the notification says.
So this is a great
example of how
we're really unlocking
the power of the Assistant
for all of you.
And there's a session
tomorrow at 11:30 AM
about designing across
surfaces, so check that one out.
And then let's say
I had a mobile app
and it includes
some authentication.
I can actually plug
into that from my Action
so that the user's
identity is shared
across mobile app and Action.
And there's a
session on day three
at 9:30 AM about integrating
mobile apps with the Assistant.
All right, so now I've got a
pretty cool experience going,
but I want to test
it further, right?
So we've already
talked about testing it
in the Actions Console
simulator, where
I can get debug
information and I
can try my Action on
different surfaces.
But while I can test
it in the console,
I can also test directly on any
Assistant-enabled device which
is logged into the
same Google account.
And we're also announcing
something really cool
that you've asked
for for a long time.
You can create alpha and
beta versions of your Actions
that can be shared with a
limited audience for feedback
and iteration.
So this means, with my Action,
I could share it to my students
before publishing live.
And there's a session with
more about testing tomorrow
at 8:30 in the morning,
so check that out.
But now you've built
this high-quality Action.
You've got some
rich responsiveness
and you've got
variation and you've
shared it with some
users and you've
iterated on the feedback.
So you're ready to
submit to a review team
and push the Action live.
So let's hear more about that.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE HIRSCHHORN: Awesome.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Jamie again.
So now that you've heard a
lot about the how and what
to build on the
Assistant, let's talk
about how you can actually be
successful on the platform.
So we think of this
in three key pillars--
discovery, monetization,
and reengagement.
As you heard from
Adam, people are
turning to their devices
and their assistance
for lots of different
things in their day.
It can be small, something
like setting a timer.
Or it can be a little
bit more meaningful,
like helping plan your day.
So whether you're building
a productivity action,
a food ordering action, a gaming
action, whatever it might be,
we know that your users are
out there looking for you.
So I know everyone's
had a long day today.
It's a little bit hot out.
Let's do a really
quick exercise.
Everyone close your
eyes for a second.
Think about the best party
that you've ever been to.
Maybe it was in college.
Maybe it was last night.
Maybe it was a wedding
or a family affair.
Maybe you remember the
smells, the food, the music.
Now imagine you were never
invited to that party.
So think about your favorite
brands, for example.
Did you take a ride sharing
service here this morning?
Did you order from a food
delivery service last night?
Do you have a favorite
game or a retailer?
Now imagine that nobody ever
told you about those brands
or experiences either.
This is why discovery
is so important
and inviting someone
to your experience
is oftentimes just as critical
as building a great experience
yourself.
So where do you get started?
The best place to start is
with our Assistant Directory.
It lives on both web and
mobile across Android and iOS.
And as a developer, once you
start a project on our AoG
console, you'll be
able to optimize
this listing in realtime.
What's really
interesting here is
that we see 30% of
third-party actions
get discovered here
in this directory.
So it's really critical to
optimize this first entry
point.
Let's talk about a
variety of use cases
here in the directory.
It starts with browsing.
So here you'll see timely
and personal recommendations
towards the top and
less contextual content
as you scroll down the page.
There's a few areas
to highlight here.
First you'll see
contextual suggestions.
These are relevant suggestions
based on the user's context--
things like time
of day, location.
And for example, here I
can see a recommendation
for my morning, like playing
my favorite playlist.
Next you'll see
dynamic categories.
You'll see a total of four
of them that are live today.
What's New, which highlights
new quality actions.
What's Popular, which highlights
overall popular actions.
What's Trending, which is
recently popular actions.
And lastly, which is the most
tailored, what you Might Like,
which is actions based
on the user's history.
The second use case that you'll
see that the directory supports
is categorical
browsing and search.
Here we're trying to really help
our users find relevant actions
in specific categories and
find their favorite actions
through a really quick search.
So let's say, for example, I'm
interested in food and drink
as a category.
You'll see all the relevant
actions here in that category,
but you'll also see some
helpful subcategories.
So for example, you can see
that you have the option
to order food from,
perhaps, Domino's
or from Dunkin'
Donuts, but I can also
get recipes from Food Network.
Finally and most importantly,
your action page.
Think of this as the welcome mat
to your brand, to your action.
It should reflect
your brand, and it
should invite users to
really try your action.
You'll see at the
top, here, there's
a quick summary, which you'll
see imagery, a description,
and sample invocation queries.
This allows the user to really
understand what your app does.
The second section you'll see--
Readings and
Recently-Launched Reviews.
This allows the user to assess
the quality of your action
before, perhaps, trying it.
So what does this
all mean for you?
How can you actually
optimize this in realtime?
How do you make your
actions stand out
with over a million actions
in our directory today?
Here's a live example
I'll walk you through.
Pretend I'm a
French bulldog lover
and I wanted to publish an
action on French bulldog
trivia.
On the left here, you'll
see that we did a few things
really, really well.
You'll see short, concise names;
strong, clear images; accurate
descriptions, whereas
you'll see on the right it
gets trimmed off a bit.
And most importantly, a
bunch of sample invocations.
So we maximize the
number of queries
that a user understands
that they can actually
use to invoke this out.
Instead of just saying, talk
to French bulldog trivia,
you'll see a variety
of invocations
such as, ask French
bulldog trivia
about grooming, for example.
OK, so now you've
built your app.
You're live with a
directory listing.
Let's talk about how built-in
intents can also help you get
discovered.
It's a great tool.
The reason we built this was
because we saw three trends.
Firstly, it's really
hard for users
to find an action for
something that they want to do.
Secondly, it's hard for
Google to actually classify
what an app can do on our end.
And thirdly, natural language
understanding is pretty hard.
So as you can see here,
there are a ton of languages.
There are dialects.
There are cultural differences.
There's slang.
That all make a
million different ways
to say the exact same thing.
So look at this
small set of ways
that a user can simply express
to say, I want to de-stress.
Built-in intents can provide
a common taxonomy for actions
across all of our
Google surfaces.
So in this scenario,
for example,
you'll see if somebody
says, hey, Google, I
want to start meditating.
We can then suggest a
few different actions
that we know will serve as that
need and are actually, indeed,
meditation apps.
So here are some of the
built-in intents that we're
working on this year.
You'll see the ones
that are starred
will be soon in developer
preview, so I really,
really encourage everyone to
check this out in Dialogflow
and see which ones
really make the most
sense for your business.
Keep in mind, we'll be rolling
lots more out this year.
It's really exciting.
The best part about
built-in intents--
and lots of these other tools
that I'll talk about today--
are that they're really,
really easy to implement.
You just log into
your AoG console,
simply pick from
a list of intents
that describes your action
best, and describe it.
And finally, here's the output
of this new infrastructure.
If somebody has a
very generic ask--
like I want to play a maps
quiz, or I want to play a quiz--
here you'll see a bunch of
different relevant suggestions
for games.
So the last tool that I'll
talk about today for discovery
is called Action Links,
which is an awesome tool
to help you promote
your experience.
You'll see, here, in
the Headspace example
that we, Google,
will actually promote
these experiences in
our own Action Link
in our own Assistant Directory,
where a user can actually deep
link directly from
the app directory
into your action on the
device of their choice.
So what's really cool
about Action Links
is that these
actually can help you
promote your own action to your
own end-operated audiences.
So everything from
your social sites--
you can see a tweet, here,
from Brad from earlier today--
or your own website,
like BuzzFeed,
where you can
actually see a user
can deep link directly from
their site into their action.
You can promote this on
apps, or even a billboard.
So it's not just
strictly limited
to digital, which
is really exciting.
We noticed that this
actually solves two problems.
One, it makes it a ton easier
to deep link into an action
directly.
And two, once the user's had a
great, high-quality experience,
they can now share this with
their family and friends really
easily themselves.
So think of all the users
cross-pollinating and sharing
your message out there.
So similar to built-in
intents, Assistant Links
is really, really
easy to implement.
You can simply generate a
URL really quickly and then
share across all
of your channels.
So now let's assume
you've knocked it out
of the park with discovery.
We'll talk about transactions
and digital goods
as an awesome way for you
to monetize your business
and grow your experiences.
So last year, we launched
transactional capabilities
via the Transactions API.
This was limited to a
phone-based experience
of physical goods and
worked really, really
well for simple transactions.
Today, you've probably
heard lots of updates
about transactions in
a few of our sessions.
But you'll see, moving
forward, that transactions
will be on more devices.
Expanding to more
complex transactions
will enable the purchase
of digital goods
and will be available
more globally.
When we talk about
transactions on the Assistant,
we're talking about
three things--
the ability for a user
to purchase a good,
hire a service, or
book a reservation
with their favorite
brand on the Assistant.
And no matter what type of
transactional experience
you're trying to build,
the foundational elements
are always the same,
as you'll see here.
The developer will always guide
the user through their purchase
process, and we
have lots of APIs
and other helpers to
walk you through this.
So I'll quickly touch on
two quick announcements that
were made today which are
really, really exciting,
and I wanted to touch
on them really quickly.
So as you know, the
growth of voice speakers
and other Assistant
surfaces in your home
has been huge this year,
and we're really expecting
it to continue to grow.
You saw our continued focus
on this in our developer
keynote today
Users can now purchase goods
and services on voice devices.
This means our users can
now complete transactions
on surfaces like Google
Home, third-party speakers,
and smart screens, which
was not available before--
really exciting.
We've also announced
that we will soon
open up the ability
for app developers
to sell digital goods
on the Assistant.
This will work across both
phone and voice surfaces
and will be supported in
multiple languages and markets,
including the US, the UK,
Canada, France, Australia,
Germany, and Japan to start.
And we're thinking of
three key use cases
here as we launch
this, and we're
really excited about diving
in deeper here and exploring
these with our partners.
In-app digital goods-- and
this is super cool for some
of the gaming developers
that I work with today--
this is the ability to purchase
gems, extra time, perhaps
characters or avatars
throughout your experience.
It's really, really exciting.
Secondly, subscription
services--
so think of things like
streaming music or video.
And lastly, digital media
purchases-- so things
like audio books or rentals.
So now to our final pillar--
you've built up this
awesome audience.
You've built an
awesome experience.
You've acquired some
users along the way.
How do you continue to
build loyalty and retention
with this great audience?
So as we've been
developing the Assistant
over the past few years, we've
thought a lot about when, how,
and where folks are actually
interacting with Google.
And we noticed that
they do this in clusters
throughout their day.
So perhaps in the
morning they do
things like ask the
Google Home about what
their day might look like.
As they're heading out the door,
they might be using navigation.
During the day, perhaps
they're searching or listening
to music.
And then later at night,
when they're winding down,
perhaps they're
listening to YouTube
or watching YouTube or
playing games, for example,
or spending time
with their family.
So what we know, here,
which is really interesting,
is that people are
creatures of habit.
So we've identified
some of these clusters
and where the
Assistant can actually
provide extra value in those
instances and micro moments
throughout a user's day.
This new feature, Routines, lets
users combine multiple actions
into a single command.
So what does that actually mean?
When you wake up in the morning
and you say hey, Google,
good morning, your Assistant
can do a few things
in one simple command.
It can turn your
phone off silent.
It can adjust your
lights and thermostat.
It can tell you about your
day, the weather, your commute.
And then it can perhaps
play your favorite podcast
or read you the news.
As a developer, you
just simply need
to check off a box to
enable this feature,
and then users can add
you to their routines.
In addition to
routines, I'll talk
about two final
reengagement opportunities
that are really exciting.
So daily updates and
push notifications.
So daily updates are
when Google can actually
share a notification and pull
an update at a specified time
each day by the user.
One example of this is you
could get transportation or news
alerts every single
morning at the same time
if Google understands
that about you.
So as you can see here--
which is an awesome example,
something that's really
content-fresh--
is that you can also see if
a user opts in to something
from Esquire, for example, they
can receive fresh daily wisdom
tips at the same time each day.
Push notifications
are really exciting,
because they can help you
do things in realtime.
So things like getting stock
alerts from your favorite news
publisher.
This is really exciting for me.
I'm a huge nerd.
It's very exciting.
I love the fact that
it's so realtime,
and it's really exciting,
because it provides a value
to both users and developers.
The value to users is that it
actually helps give you access
to relevant information which
is immediate, it's content-rich,
and it's specific to you.
What's really valuable to
brands and some of you folks
here as developers is
that this can really
help you enhance your
utility as a partner to some
of your users.
So this could be
a great experience
if you're trying to
reengage with someone
and nurture a relationship
that perhaps has fallen off
with a user, or if a user needs
a gentle nudge to push along
something that's timely.
So I know it's been a long
day out there, so we really
appreciate everyone
coming out today.
If we hope that you take
away a few things from today,
it's one-- think
about your use case.
What's the easiest
way to get started?
Templates could actually be a
really great solution for you,
so I encourage everyone
to test this out,
as Adam mentioned tonight.
And it's a really great way
to dip your toes in the water.
Secondly, please
lean in with us.
Learn more with us this week.
Check out some of
our awesome sessions
on transactions,
Dialogflow, learning more
about your audience
basis, building games.
Some of our folks are here,
which is really exciting.
So please check those
out later this week,
as you can see some of
the sessions listed here.
And lastly, we just
launched two new code labs.
You can check them out
here throughout I/O.
So thank you, everyone,
so much for having us.
Enjoy the rest of your week.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]